Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі хтось може
мені пояснити ну дуже правильне рішення
про денонсацію з білоруссю зрозуміло що
сьогодні це є окупована держава що це є
окупована Путіним територія що
лукашенківський режим - це є маріонетка
в режим але поясніть мені будь ласка хоч
хтось чому ми до цих пір маємо посла в
Мінську чому до цих пір українські посол
знаходиться в Білорусі після того як 13
місяців тому до нас звідти прийшла
смерть вбивали людей в Києві Буча Ірпінь
Гостомель
Як таке може бути сьогодні на наші
голови з Білорусії летять іскандерес 300
Дрон іранські а Ми тримаємо там посла що
він там робить Хтось може це пояснити Я
закликаю керівництво Верховної Ради
Верховній Раді лежить проект постанови
авторства пішохідного об'єднання за
демократичною Білорусь там майже всі
фракції парламенту включає правлячу
партію слуга народа автори будь ласка
винесіть її давайте визнаємо Білорусь
окупованою давайте назвемо що Лукашенко
- це є путінська шафка що це є його
маріонетка що це людина яка має разом з
ним бути в газі і проти нього теж треба
виписувати ордер на арешт а ніяких з ним
розмов ніяких послів Нащо Ми це робимо
Нащо Ми даємо Цю ж тварину в цьому
негіднику цьому картопляному фюре Які
намага ється через цю ж тварину пролізти
і повернути собі легітимність Білорусь
має бути
лукашенківський режим має бути
засуджений речі названі своїми іменами і
ще раз вітаю всіх нас з поверненням
виплат військовослужбовцям вони на це
заслуговують